News is broken that special prosecutor
Robert Muller now has enough evidence to
charge former national security adviser
Michael Flynn in the Trump Russia
investigation last weekend we heard from
sources close to the Trump Russia
investigation that yes indictments were
finally coming and they did last Monday
morning we found out about charges
against Trump associates Paul Manafort
and Rick gates we also learned about
prior charges where there had already
been a guilty plea against foreign
policy adviser George papadopolis
this weekend yesterday in fact we heard
that once again from sources close to
the probe special prosecutor Robert
Muller has enough evidence to charge
former Trump national security adviser
Michael Flynn this would be Major
prepare for the right wing talking point
oh the Flynn charges aren't a huge deal
national security adviser after all
isn't a cabinet position anyway well
that's true NSA is not a cabinet
position but it is a West Wing of the
White House position that's where the
Oval Office is that puts criminal
charges related to the Russia
investigation literally across the hall
from Donald Trump in the White House now
you'll remember manna for worked for
Trump during the campaign Flynn was
Trump's national security adviser during
the administration during the presidency
now he only lasted 24 days until he was
fired and or forced to resign and shame
but oh well don't worry Michael Flynn
had a very very limited role when were
we gonna hear that one and as a reminder
this is the guy in Michael Flynn that
Donald Trump was specifically and
explicitly warned not to hire by former
President Barack Obama the terrible guy
that Donald Trump is on a crusade
against who's trying to undo everything
that Barack Obama did he was warned by
Barack Obama not to hire Michael Flynn
oh well let's look at Obama as the real
guilty party here because Obama didn't
warn us
enough and it's really all about uranium
one or something that must be the real
story when will we hear from Sarah
Huckabee Sanders about this I presume
only after the actual charges come
forward how is she going to spin it is
it going to be oh listen Obama hired him
first
after all it's really Obama's fault it's
also interesting that the same source
that says there's enough enough evidence
to indict Michael Flynn at this point is
saying that Michael G Flynn the son of
Michael Flynn also is on the chopping
block here and if Michael G Flynn or
Flynn's son sounds familiar to you you
might remember that he was involved in
retweeting Pizza Gate related fake news
article months ago and at the time when
questions were asked the defense was oh
this is just some kid he has nothing to
do with Michael Flynn it's just his son
turns out he had enough to do with what
Michael Flynn was up to that he also may
be charged soon but maybe not because
two sources have told NBC News that
Michael Flynn the father might be able
to keep his son Michael G Flynn from
being charged if he cooperates and of
course what cooperation means depends on
the circumstances and we've been talking
about that possibility for a while right
remember when Michael Flynn through an
attorney I believe it was said months
ago he's looking for immunity if he
cooperates with the investigation there
may have been other explanations for
that but you don't really do that unless
you're at least considering and believe
you have information that would be
interesting to prosecutors we've been
talking about the possibility of Flynn
flipping ever since that and really
bringing the hammer down on everybody
but again we have to think about the
timeline right consider the meaning of
charges against Flynn this early on in
the investigation first the charges we
saw the first charges within the last
month we're already at National Security
Adviser think about what that could mean
for the next 6 12 or 18 months Flynn
could be in serious trouble it appears
that he was working with Turkey to
kipped kidnap a Turkish dissident to
send him back to Turkey realistically to
be executed but we've also learned that
while he was national security adviser
Flynn was allegedly getting cash
from the Turkish government do you
understand what it means when the
National Security Adviser is getting
money from a foreign power especially
one that's headed up by a total
authoritarian dictator like uh dawuan in
Turkey and the really wide view is that
Robert Mulder must have a ton of
evidence just a ton of evidence because
if we're at NSA just weeks after the
first charges he have must have a really
big case that he's building here and
there's another storyline with the Flynn
revelations which is that Trump CIA
director Mike Pompeo might also end up
being wrapped into this we learned over
the summer that Pompeo was acting a
little bit strangely the New York Times
report from January or from a couple of
months ago told us that by January of
2017 senior government and intelligence
officials were already worried about
Flynn they sort of suspected that he had
been compromised because of his
connections to foreign powers the CIA
was at the top of the list of
organizations that were concerned about
Michael Flynn but for some unexplainable
reason or at least as yet unexplained
CIA director Mike Pompeo continued to
brief Donald Trump in the Oval Office in
the presence of Michael Flynn now it's
not clear whether Mike Pompeo the CIA
director did this because he was
deliberately in the dark at the time
about Michael Flynn being compromised
which is possible but would be a little
bit odd is it possible that Pompeo did
know about what the intelligence
community believed to be the truth about
Michael Flynn but he decided he didn't
believe it or he believed it but he
didn't care we don't know the answer to
that but these revelations about Michael
Flynn which may very very soon lead to
indictments also raised questions about
CIA director Mike Pompeo and of course
the new paradise papers leaks raised
questions more questions about Jared
Kushner as well as Secretary of Commerce
Wilbur Ross and their connections to
Russia and we already knew four months
ago and prior disclosures that Secretary
of State the top diplomat in Donald
Trump's administration Rex Tillerson Rex
on Tillerson as somebody called him on
the on live calls Rex
Tillerson was the director of a bahamas
based us Russian oil company so this
goes deep if you still believe there's
nothing here I don't get it I don't get
it but I welcome your emails explaining
to me why that's what you think
let's take a break we'll be back after
this today's episode of the David Pakman
show is made possible in part by Warby
Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker recently
did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS